I am an equal-opportunity  boob shower you like them both I love  them both and there's NAS like both of  them the same as well let me Nicki Minaj  kind of freaking out on The Ellen  DeGeneres Show after Ellen brought up  the rapper's rumor dat new man nons I  mean it's pretty obvious and you know  he's kind of cute too so but have you  had sleepovers yet or is it just we have  you've had sleepovers yeah no let me  clarify because I know people another  thing that no what a week didn't look we  didn't do the nasty yeah I'm just  chilling right now I'm celibate and I  wanted to go a year without met you know  dating any man I hate men Oh Nicki and  her longtime boyfriend Meek Mill called  things off in January but she tells  Ellen she might just break her one-year  rule for NAS we could get that pop man  [Music]  you